at the meeting in the Algerian capital
Libya's neighbors renewed their support
for the enforcement of an arms embargo
and called for an end to foreign
involvement in the conflict that the
[ __ ] are we agreed on many principles
the only solution for the Libyan crisis
is a peaceful solution a political
solution the solution must be a Libyan
solution with support from the
international community
Libya's internationally recognized
government and political experts say
that support is vital and the only way a
lasting peace can be achieved but
they're disappointed there has not been
greater international pressure against
the United Arab Emirates in particular
which they say is supporting hafta with
arms and finance we are surprising
because the international community
cannot squeeze or convert oppressor
emeritus as we expect I don't know why
guess why why because the money may be
because the money Ward Khalifa Haftar as
forces controlled two thirds of the
country for the last nine months they
pounded the suburbs of Tripoli with
rocket and shell fire trying to capture
the capital there has been an uneasy
ceasefire for the last 10 days but there
has been violations in the south of
Tripoli the Capitals main Mattia airport
was closed after the government said it
was hit by six rockets and an unmanned
drone was destroyed both sides claimed
they had shot it down half dark forces
are blockading oil ports bringing
Libya's lifeblood industry to a virtual
standstill as oil output plummets the
cost to the economy soars
at least 77 million dollars a day but
the lost revenue will also hurt half to
our side it's already hurting because
the gas will Dibley it from Benghazi
electricity will go off and I don't
think they will be able to or to haunt
on for for a long time after hours
forces continue to receive their
salaries from the central banking
Tripoli one of the many ironies in this
complicated conflict first the Berlin
conference and now the Algerian
conference and on the 27th of this month
is going to be another conference in
Geneva the Libyan people have heard a
lot of talk about ways to end this call
but what they haven't heard are concrete
measures about actually how to do so
most Libyans are concerned with security
and day-to-day living including the
price of food and medicine it's the same
old story in Berlin or Moscow they talk
but in Libya people are dying
boys just wants to go back home he fled
with his wife and two children when his
home in South Tripoli was destroyed by
shelling home now is in a school life is
hard here we have very little and our
home was destroyed
it's not safe to go back we just want
the war to end he is one of a hundred
and forty six thousand people who've
been displaced in this conflict the hope
is there won't be anymore but in Libya
there are no guarantees
Tony Bert Lee al Jazeera Tripoli